but people are more concerned with how
Trump makes them feel yeah versus what
he's doing on the real hard to separate
that's exactly right it takes a deep
crisis of a Nation to get people think
about the real yeah but during a deep
crisis they will I saw polls
um that were like 90 days after 9 11 are
you glad George Bush is president or
would you have preferred Al Gore it was
shocking it was all the way over why
because probably 90 something percent
exactly at that point because you know
what they were thinking they were going
about thinking wait do I want Gore the
hand ringer pacing around the Oval
Office or I want the knee Breakers here
and Dick Cheney was seen as a knee
breaker